قطار يسرع عبر الظلام
ويعبر الحدود الأوكرانية إلى بولندا ،
معظم هؤلاء الأطفال هم من
دور رعاية المحتضرين في خاركيف وما حولها ، فقد كان لديه أفضل
رعاية ملطفة للأطفال في أوكرانيا
الآن وهي واحدة من أكثر المناطق التي
تعرضت
للقصف المكثف حيث تمتلئ العربة بنوع من
عاطفة شديدة للغاية
وغير مفهومة للكلمات
ولكنها أيضًا مليئة بالكثير من الحب
بين الغرباء الذين
شوهدوا في حنان لمسة
الفريق الطبي ، فالكلمات الهمسة
منك آمنة الآن
حب الأم التي
ستحفر القوة الخارقة فقط  لتحافظ على
سلامة طفلها ،
مرحبًا فيكتوريا ،
مرحبًا ، انظر إلى تلك الابتسامة
، لا تستطيع فيكتوريا المصابة بالشلل الدماغي أن
تجلس في
عصر أمها لا تعرف ماذا تقول
إنها تعاني من الكثير من الألم في روحها ،
فقط دموعها لن تتوقف.
للاقتراب من الحدود
مع بولندا قبل
أن يتمكن هذا القطار الإنساني من اصطحابهم
عصر حملت فيكتوريا لمدة ثلاثة أيام من
خلال ذعر الآخرين الذين حاولوا
الفرار مدربين لدرجة أنها لم تستطع
حتى أن تركتها حتى الآن
عملت الدكتورة يوجينيا شوشكوفيتش على
جمع العائلات معًا داخل أوكرانيا
للحصول على هذا القطار الذي نظمته
الحكومة البولندية ومستشفيات وارسو الإكلينيكية المركزية ،
إنها رحلة كان من الممكن أن تقتل أيًا
من هؤلاء الأطفال حتى بدون حرب
تلك الحقيقة  كان الفريق الطبي
قلقًا للغاية لأسباب مفهومة ، ولم
يُسمح لنا بتصوير أي شيء حتى
كان الأطفال بأمان على متن الطائرة
واستقروا
كم عمرك يا صوفيا ،
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
بينما كان هذا القطار متجهًا نحو
الأمان سمعت إيرا أن بلدتها
تعرضت للقصف
الحقبة التالية  بهدوء بينما يتم
نقل فيكتوريا من القطار ، فإنهم الآن بعيدون
عن منزلهم المليء
بالحب مثل المنزل والعائلة التي ربما لم
تعد
أروى دامون سيينا وارسو
لك